villains are joining forces and rising
up against auradon and we can't see that
we really blame them
Hades Audrey dr. facili a and uma have a
score to settle with Mel but they're not
the only ones who want to get even with
the VK we think Maleficent might be
behind the sleep spell and we've got the
evidence to back it up let's get one
thing straight Maleficent is literally
considered as the most dangerous and
feared villain of all time so letting
her spend the rest of her days as a puny
little lizard just doesn't do her
character any justice we last see
Maleficent in her human form at the end
of the first descendants movie after a
serious faceoff with her daughter mouth
Maleficent shrinks to the size of the
love in her heart which according to
fairy godmother is itty-bitty now then
asks fairy godmother she can't be like
that forever
forever is a long time she then goes on
to point out that if now learned to love
so can Maleficent could fairy godmother
Steven people are shadowing the events
of descendants three we think it might
be a possibility we last see Maleficent
aka the itty-bitty lizard in descendants
- when mal puts her into a tiny box and
takes her back to the Isle of the loss
if there's one thing we can't help but
wonder it's what happened to the deadly
lizard when mal later escaped from the
Isle it's possible that mal didn't have
the chance to retrieve the lizard seeing
as Ben had been kidnapped and the V case
had to flee the Isle in the nick of time
so what in auradon could have happened
to Maleficent
did she crawl out of the poorly secured
box and wander the isle until she found
a familiar face since lizards tend to
prefer living on the ground and often
seek rocky areas to nest
Maleficent cold-blooded instincts might
have led her to Hades quarters since
fairy godmother basically confirmed that
it was Maleficent who transformed
herself into the lizard and not now it's
possible that Maleficent could turn
herself back into a human in fact the
only thing she needs to accomplish this
is a little love if the speculations are
true and Hades is indeed mouths father
this would mean that Hades and
Maleficent have some history together if
these two villains somehow reconnected
Maleficent Hart may have started to love
again causing her to transform into her
human self there are plenty of ways
Maleficent could have ditched her lizard
skin if mal forgot her on the Isle if
not 80s then uma could have easily
raided mouths room and found the lizard
if Maleficent cursed King Steven and
queen Leah's daughter over not being
invited to a christening imagine what
she would do to the person who betrayed
her and kept her as a pet for months on
end before we get into specifics let's
take a stroll down memory lane it's a
commonly known fact in auradon that
Maleficent is the most threatening
villain in the world she has her own
display in the Museum of cultural
history due to her dark past and vile
ways you might think that Audrey's
grandmother Leah overreacted when she
first saw mal
so yeah but that's not exactly true
after all
Maleficent did curse her daughter to
prick her finger and die on the eve of
her 16th birthday a curse that would
have landed if it had not been for
merriweather's divine intervention
instead of imminent death Princess
Aurora was placed under an enchanted
sleep and still was her kingdom when the
fairies rescued Prince Phillip from the
dungeon Maleficent pet raven informed
the sorceress of their meddling however
he was soon turned to stone by
Merryweather
despite her greatest efforts Maleficent
later perished at the hands of Prince
Phillip knowing this it's understandable
that Audrey and Leah didn't take a
liking to Maleficent's daughter right
off the bat if you guys were paying
close attention you might have realized
that a sleep spell and turning people
into stone is something that's already
occurred and Maleficent story so it
wouldn't make sense for Maleficent to
want to repay the favor and how better
to do that then turn her enemies into
stone and place auradon under a sleep
spell I know it's no secret that Audrey
is going to dabble in some villainous
activity into Sun Dance 3 in the summer
of 2018 pictures of an evil looking
Audrey began circulating the web and
fans were quick to point out that Audrey
was holding Maleficent staff at first we
were led to believe that Chad
encountered an evil Audrey in the
Sherwood Forest when he left to help her
at the end of descendants two however
this doesn't exactly fit the timeline
after all
Audrey is seen holding Maleficent
sceptre and wearing the Queen's crown
which were both reported stolen by the
museum so it's safe to say that Audrey
steals these items after she returns
from the Sherwood Forest however it's
possible that she was placed under a
spell when she was stranded in the
forest and this spell may have forced
her to steal these two items and return
them to their rightful owner
during the mystery trailer who we are
led to believe is Celia that says a
great evil will have their revenge
could Celia be referring to Maleficent
shortly after the words spells are made
to be broken flash across the screen
could this be referring to the spell
Maleficent was under you know the one
that turned her into a lizard on top of
all of that the trailer stresses that
the only thing more powerful than
Maleficent scepter is Hades ember so
does this mean that the VK is only
chance at defeating Maleficent is by
acquiring Hades ember Philippa Singh
could easily possess Audrey's body of
uma lends her mother's seashell necklace
we saw evidence of this in under the sea
a descendent story when uma took over
Dizzy's body so it's possible that
Maleficent possesses the daughter of her
arch enemies and uses her as a pawn in
her game this could explain why chad
looks so terrified when standing next to
Audrey and her villainous form because
well she may look like Audrey but she's
Maleficent and seeing as Emma and mal
have a score to settle
why wouldn't she help Maleficent get her
revenge on a sidenote we'd like to point
out a small detail that might play a
huge hand in revealing Maleficent's
master plan in the Isle of the Lost a
descendents novel we find out that
Maleficent scepter dragon eye is cursed
with a sleeping spell basically if
anyone but Maleficent touches dragon eye
they will be cursed to sleep a thousand
years in the novel mal almost lets evey
touch the scepter but she has a change
of heart and grabs it before evey can
mal then falls asleep but soon wakes up
she realizes that she's immune to the
spell because Maleficent's blood runs
through her veins but Audrey isn't
related to Maleficent so why can she
touch dragon eye without being cursed
well a simple explanation for this is
that Maleficent is possessing Audrey's
body and drag and I knows this because
they share a special bond well it makes
sense that Maleficent would want her
scepter back we're left wondering what
the purpose of the crown is well perhaps
Maleficent wants to dub herself as Queen
when she successfully frees the villains
and imprisons the heroes while we do
agree that Maleficent is the queen of
Darkness we can't help but wonder how
the crown will fit on top of her mighty
horns
by now we all know that a sleep spell is
coming for Oregon and we also know that
Audrey will be affected by it when we
take a closer look at Audrey in the
mystery trailer we quickly notice that
her hair has pink and purple faded
highlights in it
this goes on to prove that the pink
haired evil Audrey exists much earlier
in the timeline if Audrey was indeed
possessed by Maleficent she wouldn't
want to tell anyone especially since she
was the one who stole the scepter in the
crown but despite her greatest effort
she simply couldn't wash out all the
hair dye however whether or not she
remembers what happened is up for
discussion regardless the look on
Audrey's face says it all she looks like
she feels guilty about something and
that's probably because a sleeping spell
is spreading throughout auradon later on
in the trailer we find out that Audrey
is affected by the sleep spell she's
seen sleeping in her bed Sleeping Beauty
style Katie seems to be trying to help
by using his Ember and we see Queen Leah
perched over Audrey's bedside worried
beyond belief cursing your enemies
daughter and granddaughter is totally
something Maleficent would do after all
revenge is all she's ever known
speaking of revenge there's someone else
who wants to see mal lose everything
she's ever loved and that's Emma it's no
secret that Emma wants to beat mal at
her own game and it looks like she'll
stop at nothing to see her dream come
true in under the sea a descendent story
uma says that's right now danger is
coming for you and you better keep your
eyes open because this time you'll never
see where it's coming from
at the beginning of the trailer though
mal runs into a blue orb in the woods
and believes it to be her father now
little is known about mouths dad except
for the fact that he's a human who
Maleficent thinks is below her mal has
often asked her mom about her father and
received little to no information so
it's safe to say that this is a major
blind spot for mal having the chance to
meet her father would be a major
distraction which could give other
villains the chance to strike now would
never expect her mother and father to be
the dangerous threats mentioned by uma
so could opening the barrier to release
Hades be a ploy that allows Zuma and
Maleficent to slip past the Isles
protective shield it's very possible
if you think omma and maleficent are
working together leave a dragon and
octopus emoji in the comment section
descendants fans are somewhat positive
that Hades is mouth dad but whether or
not Hades his mouths real father is
still up in the air
Maleficent did tell now that her dad was
a human however it makes sense that
Maleficent would lie to her daughter to
prevent her from knowing that she's a
demigod after all Maleficent likes to be
number one and probably doesn't want to
pass on the title to her daughter but
let's assume that Hades is in fact
mouths biological father this makes us
question if he'll truly be able to
betray her when the moment arises in the
media tease and is it hades trailers we
find out that the god of the underworld
is up to no good you shouldn't have come
he doesn't feel like he belongs on the
Isle and sees the heroes at the bad guys
he refers to Ben as a foolish prince and
claims that the BK's have turned their
backs on their own people saying that
he's angry would be an understatement
and we all know what happens when Hades
gets mad but then again Hades has never
really met mal or her friends and it
looks like he's going undercover to help
the BK's save auradon so what happens
when he spends time with the people of
auradon and realizes that they're not as
evil as he thought they were despite
being a major disable and edie's appears
to be misunderstood and could possibly
end up choosing goods like his daughter
once did he might end up having to
choose between Maleficent and now which
isn't an easy choice
but hey compromises do exist we're so
excited to watch descendants 3 and can't
wait to find out how the villains escape
from the Isle and wreak havoc on auradon
the final installment of The Descendants
franchise is going to be amazing and
we'd love to see Maleficent as one of
the three equals big dads so are you
guys convinced that Maleficent will play
a hand in the sleep spell let us know in
the comment section down below and feel
free to tell us if you have any theories
of your own give this video a big thumbs
up if you think now we'll be fighting
both our parents come to Senden 3 and be
sure to subscribe to the things for the
latest disney news thanks for watching
we'll see you soon
[Music]